so Thursday just when we think maybe
we're gonna get another ASMR video soon
Hogwarts Legacy dropped an absolute Bomb
by saying gameplay showcase coming up
not next week not in a month tomorrow
which is now okay first of all first
thing we're gonna do we're gonna make
sure this bad boy is set to 4K footage
right here and are you kidding me 46
minutes all right
oh nice nice
Dobby
Hedwig chocolate frog Sword of
Gryffindor collector's edition see okay
why couldn't some of that be in the
collector's edition come on man all
right so far okay I think all of this
stuff we've seen yep stuff we've seen so
far
dude how about that music though how
about that music
that might have been slightly new the
peeves slightly new there
oh my gosh I I can't believe this is 46
minutes long what's up everybody
Chandler happy first Hogwarts Legacy
gameplay stream first up we have our
team yo he brings you the latest and
greatest James
okay dude can we can we just can we just
take a moment here to appreciate this I
mean
I I feel like this is almost like an out
of Body Experience right now I can't
imagine what this was like for James you
guys I mean one of us
someone who has been covering this for
so long now he is I mean he is here
helping him present the game I I'm so
happy for him I mean this is incredible
opportunity I can't wait he's he's gonna
knock out of the park I know look at
that smile dude look at that smile oh
it's making me smile here Uncle Merlin
conspiracy theorist uh guilty as sharks
yeah no Merlin half of expecto go James
Whitehead uh thanks Charlie uh yes
um I'm James Whitehead I don't expect to
go bring you guys the latest and
greatest in Hogwarts Legacy
let's go James one half of expect to go
to where they have uh my wife Sue uh
represents that other house so um I'm
excited to be here and thank you dude uh
Avalanche how did James keep this a
secret man can I wait to go over this
game how did he keep this a secret thank
you for being here uh and we've got two
people from the studio just two look at
that the collector's edition the book
The Wand he was that close to it oh can
we also just appreciate the the
diversity of the four they've got all
four houses here I'm pretty Chandler
Slytherin James of course Hufflepuff
Alan Ravenclaw and then Boston
Gryffindor you love to see it but again
first and foremost we need to get into
this character creator and James with
you here we wanted to uh let you create
this character so let's go who is going
to be doing all of our gameplay capture
today
um these are your presets so a lot like
uh other games there's there's some
initial settings that you can put up put
can we get the in-game footage work in
progress oh that just kind of get them
into like the ballpark of what you want
to be who you want to be and what you
want to change okay please they gotta
show the final tab right you gotta show
the final time I want you in that
ballpark all the other tabs let you dial
that in all right so what are we looking
at with this option over here with the
tab okay then you go into the face a lot
of the different faces that you saw in
the in the previous screen all those
faces are are choices that you have here
so you can look at them the skin tones
and the oh my goodness interface shape
and your skin color
um and then because we're going right in
are going to want it right away and we
can just go can I go like talks purple
or green a little bit absolutely
nice this is so cool oh I like that that
is cute
okay so
um
the detail on that
oh that's pretty close to James right
now not the color different hairstyles
here let's see if that's what he goes so
now we're getting over here to there you
go around with some of those these are
more subtle options okay freckles moles
um different things like uh when it
comes to your complexion like darker
eyes
and then this this final tab here this
is where you kind of bring your whole
character together you know this is
where you finalize everything you're not
choosing your house okay that's not yet
okay okay so you got that the tone you
can go tone voice One Voice two and then
you can also adjust the pitch I like
that and then
is this our first look at the difficulty
options we knew they were going to have
difficulty options I don't want to jump
the gun here let's uh maybe James is
going to go over this channel you know
here's where you bring uh you choose
voice one or voice two which is more
kind of a masculine or feminine voice
and then even within that you're
changing your pitch
slider it's a subtle slider but yeah but
you can hear it about that was quite
something and so you can kind of make
out the differences but yeah you choose
which kind of voice that you want I like
that I like how they today we'll just go
normal because Andrew's going to be like
the Pitch Perfect experiences with
combat later and we can talk a little
more about difficulty yeah with with
combat and how that plays in but but I
think the the important thing here is
like if if for people who aren't Gamers
especially right story mode is a way to
get into this without being worried
about like oh do I need to be good at
games like no just enjoy this game and I
will probably expect though and then go
that's super interesting though that
it's four difficulties and that I'm I'm
guessing that story is even easier and
then easy whether you want to be witch
or wizard
so name confirmed though like first and
last name I know that was a big question
if we were going to be able to a lot of
people thought maybe the last name is
going to be set and we'll actually hear
people call us by that in game seems
that's not the case and then at the
bottom here you choose witch or wizard
that will determine Creator we're good
the dormitory yo let's explore Hogwarts
and let's get into something all right
it's James's character oh my gosh I love
it okay so he's got the Hogwarts fanatic
robe nice and I think I see over on the
right oh man you know we're gonna have
to do such a deep dive on this later but
right now this is just
the house fanatic robes uh from the from
the account linking you think yeah I do
look good and this is our first look at
the Hufflepuff common room soon I mean
dorm room dorm room yeah yeah this is
awesome but Alan what are we seeing
right so much on screen right now
wow so
um right now we know there's been a lot
of questions about uh
about about the HUD because this is the
first time we're showing it oh yeah lots
of questions about that kind of going
over from minimap confirmed bottom right
is what we call Our Spell Diamond so
those are everything that you see in it
are slottable spells so we have over 20
slatable spells that you can earn over
the course of the game okay and our two
three the player can place them and use
them and access them very quickly
um to the top left of that is you'll see
the d-pad and on the left eyeball and on
the right is a bit of a grid so uh the
eyeball is an example of one of not a
slottable spell but what we call an
essential spell there are certain spells
that are used in very specific contexts
or or that we just want on the
controller at all times and revello is
one of those that's left on the d-pad on
the right on the d-pad is that grid
represents where you might slot spells
the green bar is your health and
basically there's a potion next to it
that's how you might heal potions are
over there I apologize and oh okay we
know that's the ancient Magic symbol
James knows it you can tell from the
grin on his face that's going to be
related to ancient magic for sure
about a photo mode is there a photo mode
so Andrew's giving us a good look over
here I want to I want to call out uh I'm
a big fan of the bedside tables in the
dormitories
um yeah hey that's a shout out to the
Reddit right there
the bedside tables walking out into we
really tried making these low ceiling
dorms to give you that feel yeah sort of
feel the first thing I know is the music
the score is amazing with this gorgeous
and I'm calling out here uh this is
unique music that you're hearing for the
Hufflepuff common room go back to those
common Room videos we released yeah this
music's a little bit different and that
is entirely intentional
I'm sorry but I'm just so distracted by
the Spells I'm trying to figure out the
Spells over there
I want to figure out exactly how those
work so we know now it's not the d-pad
for the for the R2 spells there I forgot
what he called them go back and watch it
later figure out what exactly he called
those spells but we're a little bit
closer and they're going to show some
combat here in a minute so maybe we'll
get more then earth ravenclaws air
Gryffindor yeah Andrew's going to make
use of one of our spells rebelio let's
go right here because there's a little
magic going on okay wait how did he cast
that
because that that's one of the ones
called I think essential
so maybe it's R1 because we know R1 so
oh wait okay wait wait wait it's under
the Hufflepuff common room one must tap
the barrel two from the bottom middle of
the second row and the rhythm of Helga
Hufflepuff and Eric tap will result in
being denied access and doused in
vinegar let's go man
all right so this is called guide pages
I assume these are these are something
that we kind of interchangeably call
reveal the pages or lore pages and
you'll notice a bunch of things pop up
on the screen yeah you see that we got
some XP for it and you can also see that
we've Advanced something called like a
field guide challenge before you push
forward a little bit you can see in our
pause menu It's Got This Book theme okay
wait hold on did that say any other
students what did that say over here on
the left pause for roll
roll what is it rolling over there I
could see a question mark before you
push forward a little bit quickly turn
it in our pause menu It's Got This Book
theme wow that's your Wizard's Field
Guide and you can see your oh dude this
is so gorgeous
platinum trophy 100 field guy Pages here
I come
over
all the portraits
grand staircase flu Flames location
discovered
let's go dude the icons and the menus
it's so Sleek it looks so good right
notice the flu flame just ignites right
there which was so cool
what did they say right there
but they're they're just like in the
books yeah right to the Great Hall it's
a non-to-lord house points is not a core
mechanic or system in the game it is we
narrowed it into like a gameplay system
but it's definitely present throughout
our narrative and and there are lots of
choices where we want your dogs to
things that aren't aren't necessarily
gameplay systems but yeah but we nod to
them as as part of the narrative over to
the right part of there Andrew was
teasing that's the Great Hall over
through those doors again we're not
going there we're he's just kind of like
oh
cool can you show us what that page is
up there uh here's another collectible
page yeah just again showing you like
just these things around here yeah so
that you can
do and pick up and okay wait so we did
accio on that one I want to see if the
icon here's another challenge you know
just again showing you like just oh
there it was there was there was okay
look at the look at the bottom right the
spell wheel there it is so Triangle
Square Circle X that's that's how you do
the Spells but then but then where does
R2 come in so do you hold maybe hole R2
and then press X or
yeah because something has to make that
menu right there pop up anywhere you see
you can go just confirmed by Alan
Jackson it might look a little familiar
to you um I thought I recognized it I
believe this is from the spring ASMR and
yes so that puzzle right there that view
uh Andrew is taking us right back what
was with the cloud over here not to
interact with that but I want to keep
moving on
we can't give you everything
this is a big hub
of the school it's a big castle but
it is designed so you shouldn't get very
lost this is kind of a Grand Central
Station what a challenge man you know a
challenge screen over there so the
greenhouse is over there and let me tell
you I will be the one put to the test
because I am terrible with directions
absolutely terrible in life in games
everything across the board oh dude look
at that this is a mate this I'm kind of
getting Ministry of magic vibes from
this right here Transfiguration
Courtyard you know the library straight
ahead so it's kind of a
they're all gonna have names
is everything all right yes I'm sorry
I'm enjoy talking about this I'm Nelly
by the way I'm just so excited that the
daily and keys are back the walk Keys
the dedalian keys surely you've seen
them flying about rumor is that a former
headmistress Professor mole conjured
them to protect the contents of certain
law okay former headmistress Professor
mole
I'll have to check later but I think
that may have just confirmed Phineas as
the Headmaster cabinets years ago
Professor black couldn't be bothered to
disenchant the Keys and they appear
every few years
you should try to catch one
why would I do that
cabinet somewhere in the castle if you
can manage to get the key into the
cabinet lock not an easy task you may
find a reward
oh some dialogue options here so Nelly
ogspire if you can manage to get the key
in the cabinet lock not only okay I'll
look into it why would I had misters do
such a thing why don't you follow the
keys
is this James playing right now perhaps
he'll give it a go I hope you do it okay
in fact I think I heard one of the keys
in the astronomy Tower you should listen
for them
uh different interactions with different
characters can also offer different
Choice points for the player and then
some of those things can can affect
things game wide some of these affect
characters lives uh the ending of the
game
um and sometimes it's just about you
being a little bit better just being a
jerk
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa Allen whoa
whoa things are okay can some of those
things different Choice points so uh Can
Can Am I reading too much into this
probably affecting this game wide some
of these
so our choices do matter no morality
system but the choices do matter and do
have an impact I think he just confirmed
that right there and then he's about to
talk about the end of the game and I
feel like he started to say a little bit
more and then stop short affect
characters lives uh effect
let's go dude ending of the game
um and sometimes it's just about you
being and Chandler's like nothing
there's just no more absolutely so the
scale really varies but but uh but those
opportunities exist for the player wow
look at this thank you I gotta say this
is not what I thought it was going to be
like this is a totally different vibe
that they were going for which which is
cool you know the state of play it was
just like boom boom boom like
huge thing after huge thing this is a
much more like I feel like for the for
the fans who have followed this for a
long time and want to obsess over all
these little details obviously that's
why they got James there right I mean
James is the king of that so it's it's a
very different feel to it than some of
the other trailers
notably a younger student yeah a first
year or an 11 year old do they have
their finger on the pulse of everything
because remember some people were
wondering and some people were talking
about are there any younger kids in
Hogwarts in this game
they've clearly heard us talking about
that are you all right
oh
hold up is this the Ravenclaw companion
is that did we just get introduced to
the Ravenclaw companion oh
uh gobstos is one of the things that is
not playable in the game
um I know we've we've had to rip the
Band-Aid off on a few things I honestly
it's both in a it's an amazing thing on
the franchise how many things about this
like like speakers fans and that we want
to turn into true and and there were
calls that we had to make over the
course of production of quidditch which
things we will and won't include yeah
those are things that aren't featured
within the world I'm glad they're
mentioned they're a part of the
Wizarding World yeah every single time
being in a classroom I think this is a
good opportunity to talk about how
classes work oh my God a lot of
questions about that is it a schedule
based system is it to tell us how
classes work yeah so um ultimately
decided not to go the Sim route so I
think like one of the speculations was
is there time of day and you know that
kind of thing like can I miss class at
this time of day there is a day night
cycle yeah yeah there's a day night
cycle but uh but everything is very um
narrative based and so there's a big
industry going on of the world there's
something happening in the narrative and
we and we essentially see it as kind of
like chapters in that narrative each
chapter of which has a set of missions
that you can choose between as you're
progressing through the game and classes
fit within that structure so the
mainline things the players have to do
and then classes also appear on the
sides as well as optional things that
help you advance your spells it's
absolutely true that classes provide all
of your major tools throughout the
gameplay interesting your major
abilities you get to know the professors
each one of them has these bespoke kind
of events yeah those missions and then
there are also additional opportunities
outside of that I feel like that was the
best side solution honestly
you're just gonna get lost in this
Castle you guys just a little bit
wait what did that say there you go yeah
don't try to just slide right by that
level one lock
interesting different yeah sentient
Castle full of magic for hundreds of
years it's going to kind of grow and
develop oh I heard something yeah
speaking of characters
Mr Magic himself
oh messing with the first years you know
we talked about building on lore too
another set statue over to the side you
know who that is Lachlan the lanky and
he's got his bow truckle friend and nice
job Chandler oh there's another
okay bottom left look at all of those
little nodes on that mini map right
there
are those all of the oh those must be
the gobstones okay yeah find zenobius
gobstone zero of six this is a really
good opportunity to now jump into combat
because really in the game this is going
to be uh the first time where you
yourself get to learn about combat and
combos in a big way trying to absorb
everything channel the game like really
starts to open up to the possibilities
uh
so we've set up uh We've set up a
training dummy and this is an activity
where you're supposed to execute
according to kind of the iconography on
the top now what we see on the top is
the accio spell yep for what we just
kind of lovingly refer to as basic shots
there's basic shots it's kind of like
used just kind of fling Andrew's using
one now
trigger that by tapping R2 on your
controller so you can see in the corner
R2 so if you tap R2 that throws out a
basic shot oh okay okay dude
they should have just called it
flippindo first of all
but I'll allow
so that's kind of like a basic shot the
R2 is just for that basic shot okay now
how do I cast accio who is also your
gateway to all of the the uh spells that
you might slop shot but that R2 is also
your gateway to all of the the uh spells
that you might slot so if you hold R2
instead you can see here we go the
diamond expands there we go let go you
see how it contracts yeah and so if you
hold it again it expands and so when it
expands and all the spells that you
slotted while you're holding that button
can now be tapped with your face buttons
awesome and not only that but over the
course of the game you can gain
um additional spell diamonds up to four
additional ones so that you can slide
this to 16 spells you know pretty much
instantly and then that helped us
um fulfill the fantasy of in combat I
need to be able to access things very
rapidly yeah and and so you learn over
the course of these there it is you know
how to juggle not just the spell casting
but also it reinforces an understanding
of another feature of the wheel which is
their cooldowns so as you're casting
spells just to make sure that you're not
just kind of like repeatedly using one
thing over and over again you can see
cooldowns on the spells that he's using
uh on the wheel they all have a cool
down to the game there are different
things that can affect things like
cooldowns through your talents yo okay
I'm trying to decide how much of this I
should try and figure out versus just
letting Alan explain it here I do want
to read this though breakthrough Violet
Shields with four spells like the
summoning charm Akio to manually Target
enemies and objects use R3 to lock on I
love that and then the right stick to
change targets
um so uh you're not the only one that
has protego and the ability to deflect
the enemies do too and we actually play
with that when it comes to slow casting
so you notice that there are different
colored kind of shields around the
different characters and you also notice
that your spells have different colors
on them so to help players understand
kind of like the functions we've got to
put them into brackets so there are
damaged spells there are four spells
there are freaking in the other one all
the control spells and so those things
for the player they wind up also being a
color indicator for which which actual
spell to use to break the different
Shields that uh enemies can use that way
interesting
dude I can see this absolutely being one
of those system that is
easy to get into but very difficult to
master I don't feel like you're just
going to be able to spam maybe that's
going to be one of the differences
between the difficulty levels
because that I mean the simple combo
with like R2 is I forgot what exactly he
called it it's essentially flippindo
just that very basic spell that's kind
of like a combat spell maybe even
stupefy I don't know stupefy mic
qualifies a little bit higher tier than
a flippindo but having to cycle between
those
man that's gonna be interesting I think
it's gonna take it's definitely going to
take it a little bit because I've I
don't know that I've ever seen a system
quite like this today but uh we'll we
will definitely be taking you in dude
dude
they said you can
Alan said earlier that you can go
anywhere
oh new trailer
new trailer let's go
oh my gosh the lion
I love those windows dude oh there's the
the creepy little first year lost their
gobstones
nice look at the combat
oh my goodness man we're gonna have to
the shot of the hippogriff yet again
they really did name everybody
ashwinder Scout Ash Wonder wait wait I
want to go back to that last
that last shot right here I think that
is that room of requirement
it's like the the vivariums
oh my goodness wow so totally different
feel not at all what I was expecting
honestly this was a very different uh
style especially compared to what
they've done we've really seen their
marketing team kind of try a lot of
different strategies here in terms of
how they show the game how they're
talking about the game this was way more
laid back than I was expecting you know
that like I said earlier that state of
play it was just a constant flood of
information so when I saw it was 46
minutes before I started I was I was a
little bit worried because I was
thinking oh my gosh you know are they
going to show too much here but they
didn't I thought it was a good balance I
thought we got um a lot of little
tidbits here and there you know some
some things that people might not be too
happy about you know the the Wizard
Chest thing and the gobstones thing but
so much there to be excited about and
the thing that I've wanted more than
anything else in this game that I'm so
pumped about is is one thing that they
all keep talking about how much they
love it's that exploration of the castle
and you just truly getting lost in there
and just finding all these little
secrets and finding all the discoveries
so I can't wait to see I feel I'm
starting to feel much more confident
about that aspect is going to be just
nailed absolutely the combat our first
major look at the combat that's going to
be interesting man I'm really gonna have
to pour over those details maybe cut up
those sections where they talk about
that specifically to try and figure all
that out in my mind exactly how that
works because we've got the d-pad for
some type of spells and then R2 is kind
of like just a basic stunning spell then
if you hold R2 it opens up even more
spells so
rest assured man the next few weeks and
three months leading up to Hogwarts
Legacy are going to be absolutely crazy
in terms of content
you guys know where you can always find
more as always thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon